what up guys welcome to another JK
overtime this is where we get to get
girls in person personal we get real
personal and JK over time especially we
got Nick because this guy's king of
deflecting all the time but now there's
no one to deflect to it's just me and
Nick
and you're already rubbing your eyes
what's the problem what's the [__]
problem I don't know why I'm nervous
this is this is making me nervous well
let's take it back so are you nervous
no you're you're immune to this this is
like you're good to go well because I
never deflect so everyone else like
I'm trying to figure out how to deflect
for a whole hour so on Ryan and
Anthony's uh episode they started off
um and I'm actually really a fan of that
episode that was a great episode because
I know they've known each other for a
long time but I didn't know there was
like history almost outside of dance
yeah there's history in UCI and all that
stuff yeah so I think it'd be cool if we
go back to maybe when we first met
I remember that now what was our first
impression you go first okay my
recollection and I could be wrong what
years is let's date this this is
probably like 2017. this is when I was
still at my old uh gym fight Academy
yeah my home gym and out in Pasadena
shout out to them if you guys want to do
MMA classes in Pasadena go check it out
um but yeah I was working out of there
and I was training David at the time and
this is when David was going through his
weight loss journey and he was really
into kickboxing and all that right and
he was like hey why don't you train like
let's do a group training I'll bring
Bart and Joe how did you guys even link
up though you and David I think he just
found me on Yelp on Yelp Just on Yelp
did he ever tell you like did he look up
fight Academy or MMA trainer he said he
just looked up like private kickboxing
lessons and then I popped up apparently
he said he thought I was just gonna be
this white guy and when I saw him on
Yelp yeah I'm on Yelp dude why did you
say that with this oh gosh dude because
you suck at social media dude well
that's how that's how I got all my
clients exactly what [__] David did
private
private it's definitely changing now
I don't know if it happens no that's
[__] [__] I don't believe David
or you Pasadena check it out all right
look at this private kickboxing lessons
I'm not gonna probably guarantee you're
not gonna pop up yeah but that was like
Alonso martial arts a large shout out to
Alonso Krav Maga Unleashed yeah impact
personal safety okay so you gotta scroll
a little bit longer okay maybe maybe my
search engine opportunity Academy of Los
Angeles yeah yeah yeah that's me that's
it
shantan Kung Fu Legacy Vibes La that's
the dance competition I'm gonna go all
the way down all the way down to like
number
number 19. hodori martial arts okay dude
okay you made your point all right you
made your point you don't need to go to
the 25th so that's [__]
no it was
yeah it was I think and I don't know I
honestly not Instagram no it was Yelp oh
and then he later followed me on
Instagram because I remember being like
this blue Tech this is back in the day
when Instagram was like still kind of
popping off right and then I was like
this guy with a blue check mark followed
me and I was like who is this and I saw
his page and I was like oh [__] I think
I've seen this guy's YouTube channel
before and I saw he was with you guys
because I knew who you guys were yeah
yeah I knew who you guys were from just
for my YouTube I just knew you guys did
skits and you guys did the accents uh um
I just yeah that was my my analogy you
guys
um
fast forward to you guys bringing all
your ladies
right yeah yeah you guys all did like a
a giant training session with us and it
was really fun and I was like wow you
guys are really cool really nice and I
just remember
kind of uh I was like definitely like
okay this is because this is like the
first time I had like
celebrity clients you know I mean you
guys were like you guys were some big
names and I was like oh [__] just don't
be an idiot just just do what you
normally do and then Shane Faison came
too yeah which is also all in the same
one I think it was the same one really
yeah I think so because I met that's
when I met Geo for the first time
because I remember thinking Jesus Christ
she's the tallest woman I've ever met in
my life I think Shane came maybe a few
sessions later you know what dude it
doesn't matter
okay so how many
um
what was your first impression of me
specifically I was like this guy's a big
deal that's what I thought it's a big
deal what just in selling cars yeah well
well and like the YouTube space or just
social media I was like oh this dude has
like a crate like dude this guy has I
remember thinking like 600 000 people or
whatever like following you on Instagram
I was like dude this is crazy and also
too this was my first time even with
training with David anytime he would
post me on anything like
I would get so many people just hitting
me up randomly like following me and I
was like what and it was like the first
time I've ever seen anything like that
so the whole social media game in
general was like so new to me so the
fact that you guys are coming from this
space and
from other people that I've heard that
trained other influencers that are like
oh yeah dude they're kind of like some
of the worst clients they've ever had so
I was like all right let's just see how
this goes out because I was kind of very
skeptical
but when I met you guys I was like man
you guys are really down to earth and
you guys are just really cool and you
guys are silly goose time and I was like
this is kind of right up my alley so
immediately I remember thinking like man
you guys are really nice and I remember
thinking I remember being pleasantly
surprised and just being like cool
awesome and then from there it just kind
of blossomed into what it is today where
you guys asked me to to do this show
what about the first time training did
you have any like like you look at Joe
or you look at me well let's just talk
about me because I'm here yeah yeah when
he looked at me did you think oh this
guy's gonna be like this or whatever and
then when we trained really man I try to
be because every time I have too many
expectations going in to a training
session or just even a new client like
you kind of have to be really good at
having a clean slate I think from from
how I run
um
when I see new clients that are just
meeting new people so I try to have a
blank slate and just be like
from whatever I observe that's what I
observe and that's what I'll make my
judgments from I'm not going to try to
take it from there because I remember I
was very thinking from a very uh like
technical aspect like oh Bart's got some
good roundhouse kicks and he's got some
good body awareness like that's that's
pretty much what I was thinking but now
I don't think that anymore I think it's
it's garbage
mine was the exact opposite yeah what
was yours yeah so I'm the way that I
like to work I don't like to keep an
open mind yeah I like to judge [__]
hard and then I make sure that other
person earns it from me
so uh when David told me started
training I fight Academy I don't care I
heard of that place before
and I stopped by a couple of times like
back in the day I'm not okay whatever
you sharing with an old Muay Thai coach
yeah yeah
or something like who else goes no no
this guy named Nick I was like who the
[__] this thing no one knows what the
[__] Nick is and you wouldn't be correct
and then he showed me I think a link to
either the fight Academy page or
whatever and then I there's like a
picture of you I'm not sure if you still
remember because I have like [__]
autistic memory
there's a picture you've kind of laid
like this and I saw your cauliflower
ears I was like okay you got some
cauliflower so he knows what he's doing
and then I remember showing up and then
this is when I first rolled my eyes I
saw you have do you remember your yellow
Shin Shin pads yeah yeah yellow shin
pads and matching yellow gloves yeah I
was like oh he's one of those
[__] the guys that have to get
the loudest gear in the [__] room and
then I remember we had another session
so that was striking I feel so judged by
the way for sure I'm gonna judge you
like crazy that's how I work and I
remember having another session and it
was like a rolling only session and you
had like a [__] polka dot rash guard
yeah purple yeah I still have it I was
like this is the [__] with the
loudest gear I got the room can I tell
you the backstory I got that on sale by
the way so continue why would you why
would you get a purple polka dot you
know what I was really into polka dots
at the time and I still wear it to this
day so I still kind of am and I got it
for a good deal so and do you still use
that yellow gear no I I gave those
actually away you did I gave those away
but I remember going okay this is that
[__] I'm like all right he likes
to be the [__] Class Clown or
whatever probably prom king or some
[__]
um and it's all I already kind of had
like a shield yeah but what I thought
was really cool
was uh when we first started training I
never felt like oh like because some
some people you know like the reason why
I think they're Fighters
or dancers even or whatever or like
physical movement people I feel like
they can communicate better with their
physicality so they kind of like to
establish pecking order with their body
I never thought that I was like okay
this Fool's gonna come he's the loudest
guy with the gear he's gonna [__]
come Light Me Up Just to let me know
what time it is and then like kind of
put everyone in order based off of their
movement yeah but I could see you
sparring with me at my level oh yeah we
did Spar for the first yeah that's cool
that's really cool and then I remember
the other session because I've been
talking because I just didn't feel
threatened at all that's why thank you
that's why I didn't feel like this guy
was gonna kick my ass I was like oh dude
it's like sparring with like a small
little [__] yeah and then I remember
bringing in Shane and then that's when I
saw you and Shane go at it I was that's
tight so I saw like your skill level and
then you saw Shane bring his skill level
from here all the way down here to meet
me so he didn't beat me I did see him
put on a blindfold
he was still jabbing me and I was like
what the hell yeah so that was and then
it was really good by the way and then
seeing you uh trained David and then
seeing David continue because like David
is also someone I really trust his
judgment yeah like David doesn't hide
anything he's the most critical guy I've
ever yeah he doesn't like you he's like
[__] you to your face I'm not gonna talk
to you anymore I was also skeptical of
him when I first met him too really why
yeah because I was like what's this
guy's deal dude he's like being really
nice to me and he was like I thought he
was trying to get something out of me
but maybe you know that's just past
traumas or something I don't know yeah
no Dave is like one of the most realist
dudes no he is and it took me a while
because he would tell me stories about
things and I'd be like this guy's full
of [__] because it's sometimes when he
tells stories it sounds like he's lying
but it's but if you've been in those
stories then you know they're all real
for sure but then I've met enough people
that have corroborated all these stories
where I was like oh David just doesn't
like he just he just really interesting
at telling stories and that makes me mad
but continue sorry yeah so like uh
seeing him vouch for you and seeing him
continue with sleep train with you I was
like okay cool like
um you know when you're like as famous
as I am
sure sometimes you're like no it's true
though you don't know if every
relationship is worth keeping open yeah
because honestly or Genuine because you
meet so many people you don't know how
genuine they are you don't know the next
time you're gonna see them or I'm like
is this person the uh once a year I see
you at the [__] Gala type person and
with high five yeah or are you gonna
make it into like my actual house party
where I'm Gonna Give You covet through
which I didn't go to if I give everyone
else covet so I want to know how close
we're gonna be am I going to give you
covert or not yeah and so like I usually
like keep that distance for a while
until I saw that you and David kept
hanging out and then um and I would come
train he kept keeping me around
yeah you know which I was surprised by
and I was like okay cool if David's
gonna keep this fire lit I'm gonna keep
this fire that too and you're really
cool and you earned the uh you took away
my judgment ice oh that's cool I didn't
think I was gonna be able to do that I
still what kind of judgments you got
about me now bro no none really yeah
because you are you I would imagine you
would have more just
no for me it's at the beginning I judge
everyone [__] hard like the most
stereotypical thing I'm racist I'm
[__]
um Aegis that's actually a funny story
so I was actually uh really racist two
times and both times I was right so that
or were you racist then I don't think so
so the first time was the fact of the
matter you know my first Vegas house
yeah yeah I'm at my next door neighbor
black dude right yeah six six kind of
got a good build I was like he's an
athlete so I got his name Google them
right I was like see it [__] racist I
knew he played in the NBA and then yes
or two days ago I was walking my dog I
saw some dude backwards hat I'm not even
gonna tell you the skin color yeah
backwards like we already know he's just
he's on his knees pulling weeds out
which is so much swag that no other race
could move like that and I was like okay
who is this guy again we talk a little
bit I Googled his name and he's a ref
for the NBA no way so he has that like
basketball swag he's around it it's
gonna rub off yeah yeah so I was just
like two times racism two times right
I think the sample size of the times you
were racist and you were right I think
it was real small right now I think
you're riding really high I bet there's
way more instances where you were like
potentially racist and that was wrong
and you were also right but you're just
only thinking of these two that's just
probably 100 out of 100. there's
probably like you're probably maybe a
thousands
so moving on to from there when did we
start
like hanging out more I think a lot of
it and the cool thing about training and
I'm sure you've experienced this too you
just meet a lot of cool people through
just training together yeah right and I
think you could learn a lot about
somebody who they really are when you
see them in the gym and you work out
with them and then things like etiquette
how they carry themselves how they like
communicate with other people so I think
you could you could get a good sense of
that
um so a lot of our ours hanging out
sessions even with Joe David was or even
Yoshi too because Yoshi would train with
us all the time
um was all through training and I think
that people that stick around that we
got really good friends with that became
like people that I could trust and rely
on or all through the guys who just
stuck around and were just train even
like Jason Chen would train with us
every now and then and he still trains
with me to this day after what like two
three years now and then even like Alex
Resurrection all these guys like so
we've kind of built a lot of um
like yeah just relationships through
just being in the gym together and then
I think and then it started coming to
like hey you want to come watch the
fights right at in the house where you
lived over there and and then it was
like the marathon training and then just
kept happening where you would just be
like hey let's train let's train let's
do this and then we'd link up and then
from there we I think a lot of um I
noticed the pattern though is me asking
you how come you never asked me yeah
that's true it's asked you to come over
that's true marathon with me yeah let's
come train how come you never asked me
to go like play with your dogs or go on
a hike I'll say this that's something
I'm really bad at not bad at it just
like I don't do that a lot with friends
and that's something even with my best
friends like my closest friends are
growing up I don't really
Reach Out
to say like hey let's hang out it's more
of like they hit me up and they go hey
you want to do this and then I'm like
okay cool what do you think that says
about me dude so that make me a bad
person I think you got trauma
I might I might but yeah I think I do
hang out but you don't ask anybody
but people ask you yeah so I think you
got some trauma or something I think I
got some issues dude who's your best
friend what's the name of your best
friend do you have a best friend yeah or
is it like a group that's all types yeah
I think I got a best friend you do
what's his name is Frank
[Laughter]
how long have you known Frank I've known
since high school okay what makes him
your best friend compared to everyone
else out there
see these are hard-hitting questions
yeah I think he understands
me on another level that um most people
don't
um actually
I take that back he understood I think
he understands me very well so let's say
some [__] happens crazy [__] I could
always rely on him some crazy [__]
happens you text Tiff first or you text
Frank first I'll ask a good question
I'll text to First what why Tiff first
and not Frank it depends on what the
situation is really if it's something
that I feel like I need assistance like
like a physical male assistance I'll
probably call
my boy Frank but if it's something
that's like like an emergency something
like really serious I'd probably call it
Tiffany first
what would you let's say you're on the
710 going north yeah a [__] semi
truck flips over the whole thing's
blocked yeah
and you see everyone driving to go pick
up their friends from their freeway
because they're they have to leave their
car there who do you call I'll call to
probably you'll call Tiff yeah the one
you call Frank what do you tell Frank
God damn it this guy's good at asking
questions because as soon as you answer
the question you ask the question in my
head I go yeah I know yeah
the person I rely on the most so your
best friend's technically Tiff probably
yeah technically Tiff and then Frank is
if there's
an answer form you need to fill out
who's your male bet you're like I guess
I have to write that down
yeah yeah I I think that's that's the
more accurate uh we'll just say it's
like this though so tips up here and
then Frank's down here or is it like
this I think it's
and also too it's time has changed I
think with me being married yeah you
know like yeah yeah yeah yeah I think it
makes me change how I look at the world
and how I move forward and how I like
make decisions yeah because you're gonna
spend the rest of your life with this
person exactly exactly and um so I think
most of it will come down to to because
I'm sure it's the same thing with you
right like if some [__] hits the fan
who's the first person you're gonna go
uh first person you're gonna call so I'm
[__] okay and that's why I like
um in probably 20
15 maybe
oh no no a 2013 2014 me and Geo had a
really rough patch in our relationship
to the point where we thought we're
going to break up and everything and in
that super rough patch
um one of the most [__] things is I
think Geo would always hear the news
last even when we knew we were going to
be together
but I'm such a boys type of dude yeah
that
um me like something happens I like the
boys uh reactions to things I like how
we can immediately joke about something
and maybe that's my own internal trauma
trying to avoid the emotional aspect
it's easier to spread like oh my dad Dad
it's easy to like talk with the dudes
about that versus like oh my [__]
damn man what the [__] versus one of the
emotional route yeah yeah I think I'm
such that that it was it was more
natural for me to like
go through the boys and so me not
knowing that I'm actually alienating her
from her being like my
my significant other role you know so
like it took me a while
to maybe even a year after we got
married to like
she's my number one person yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think I went through
that earlier in our relationship like
even before we got engaged yeah because
I would kind of do that and then she'd
always like feel some type of way about
you know ladies bro let's be real women
am I right
no but it's just like
um
she would get upset about how I would do
the same thing like everybody else would
know my plans and even yeah before she
would right and she would feel some type
of way and I don't blame her because
she'd always be like well why are you
not telling me and like I wouldn't even
tell her at all like she would and it
would be through conversations with my
friends when she's around and then she
would hear it and be like what the [__]
how can you tell me yeah that's exactly
how it happened it'd be like that and
then I get mad at them and I go why the
[__] are you guys bringing this up in
front of Tiff that's what I do I know
for mine I'd be like we're all laughing
about it and it's almost like an inside
joke that we've been laughing about for
years yeah but then it's news to her so
she feels like outside of like
like um you know like intimacy like
there's like I think true intimacy is
like how well we know each other she
felt outside of that yeah and I was like
oh [__] I've been doing this thing going
back to the whole lady thing right and I
think just women and it took me a while
too it just women just perceive and take
things differently as well like how they
want to show love is different than how
I want to show love and how they receive
love is very different too or how they
communicate I think is like kind of
different they're [__] too did you
did you hear the recent box we're gonna
just bash women dude no I'm [__] the
women also [__] did you hear the
most recent the most recent boss rooting
on Joe Rogan no no what was he saying
okay so they're talking about how like
Fighters bringing family to their fights
yeah right and they say it's never a
good thing yeah because win or lose like
they they can't take it they're not in
the sport for a reason I feel like it's
a bad idea mostly a bad bad idea
um so for Boss rooting
he for one of the fights he was uh it
was one of those like two fights in a
month in Japan so he's like well might
as well you guys like my wife just come
because I'm gonna be here for a while
he brings his wife and I think for most
people they would they don't want their
wife there because they don't want to
see they don't want to get beat up in
front of the wife yeah for sure but boss
Rootin in this round was whipping the
[__] out of the other guy the wife
stands up and walks away guess why why
guess because she didn't want to see him
beat the [__] out of some other guy so
this is how dumb chicks are
she she thought that he was going to be
extra aggressive and hurt him even more
because she's there so if she walks away
he would have no one to impress and then
he would just beat him regularly I'm
like that's a way of thinking that no
guys
ever could even think that convoluted
that's an interpretation of what women
think men think right and I think that's
where people get in trouble yeah it's
like she's entrepreneur exactly and
that's when I try to think I try to be
smart guy and be like well Tiff's a lady
so she's thinking about this issue this
way therefore I will approach it this
way and it usually blows up in my face
every single time you know like where I
try to like jump ahead of the situation
and I just do more damage because of
that do you feel like you do the same
thing I bet you do don't look at me like
you know I think now what I learned
about the key to being in relationships
as being as meta as possible is what I
learned do you agree or no give me an
example I don't even know what meta
means meta means like talking about the
thing or talking about
so just having an open conversation no
no but like like
um
because I think the guys have the
tendency of trying to fix problems yeah
100 right that's me so chicks will say
this whatever and then like the first
thing you hear is like oh why don't you
problem solve right why don't you do
this why don't you do this yeah and then
it took a while for her to go
I'm going to vent right now don't try to
problem solve yeah it's like very meta
yeah yeah talk about what we're going to
talk about and then she would say that
and then I would say like Okay cool so
I'm able to process that and then now
just kind of be like the shoulder to
lean on and then not give advice or
whatever and then the the same way where
if like now I think we're really good at
communicating where if I'm frustrated
I'll just go I'm frustrated and then
that way if I
um have an attitude about something like
oh what do you want from Postmates I
mean then she knows oh it's from the
other thing he talked about yeah so I
felt like the being meta really helped
our but also feel like that's how you
yeah diffuse it or else the way we think
and the way they think is way different
yeah I know always assuming the wrong
[__] yeah because I think for me
you have to spell everything out for me
because I'm a little slow yeah you know
what I mean like you got to really paint
by numbers for me that way I'll
understand oh this is what we're doing I
get it this is how we move forward
because it is such a collaborative
effort to ever try to pull sexy times on
you and then you just didn't even see it
because you didn't spell it out yes what
did she do well it
I still don't even know to this day she
doesn't tell you after she told me after
she's like how come you didn't so what
did you what did you do
I mean what would she do what does she
do and how did you read it she she's
very subtle she's like super subtle I
think most chicks aren't witches yeah
she was like I put my I put my hand on
your shoulder and I was like what dude
really that's what no I forgot what it
was specifically but it was something
along those lines of it completely went
over my head and then the next day she
was like how you weren't you weren't
down to you know you weren't down a
clown that's what she says that's the
chick's problem too why do they wait
till the next day yeah why don't wait
till the next day [__] grab my face
we literally had like eight hours laying
there
you want to be a gentleman right you
don't want to like you know yeah in my
head
maybe this is a trauma in my head my
wife is never down to clown okay right
but that's not true but in my head I
just be like oh man like I bet she's not
down to do anything right yeah so maybe
you guys have a good clowning frequency
what's a good clown of frequency I don't
think it's up to the couple yeah I think
what are you guys at
I think it's pretty good what's pretty
it's pretty good
maybe come Monday Wednesday Friday once
a quarter
once a fiscal quarter no um
I think on average because it's
different first and 15th yeah
I think at least once a week on average
that's pretty good right yeah maybe but
I'd like to get those numbers up yeah
you know I know what you mean but what
is like a frequency that you guys do
like how often do you guys I would say
throwing it down
pre-kid
um I would say probably yeah down a
clown once a week maybe that's pretty
solid and then I think as we got busier
now it's probably once every two weeks
maybe once a month even got it because
by the time we like we'll talk about it
during the day like we're both clowning
yeah I'm like we should do something we
should do something about this
and then because you guys are all
business too it's about time we get to
bed we're both [__] exhausted do you
send her like a Google calendar invite
and make sure you're like hey dude you
didn't RSVP what what we'll try to do a
verbal invite and then it's locked in
for sure yeah how often do you guys lock
it in verbally and then you guys don't
follow through
so two nights ago we locked it in yeah
and then I had a [__] headache out of
nowhere
and then I was like oh [__] internet
screens too long dude yeah I had a
[__] headache that came out of
nowhere yeah
and so that that didn't happen so my
follow-up question is because you're
you're
I feel like you're epitome of discipline
and Fitness in the JK realm right you're
the guy
does a part of you call yourself a
quitter when you can't make it in yeah I
do I bet so that's what we talked about
the other night where last night uh we
were like are we gonna do it tonight and
then she was like well you are you
talking [__] too are you yeah I'm
[__] I'm a rock your world yeah well
you didn't even do it
as soon as I brought it up yeah that was
your you I saw her take it as an out too
because I know she was tired yeah yeah
so she was like relieved yeah if you're
relieved yeah then I'm not gonna push
any further yeah so that's true so we
weren't down the clown girls do act
relief sometimes when they get relieved
of their duties because I feel like when
they really want to yeah they won't take
no for an answer yeah yeah yeah yeah
which is kind of rare right that is
actually kind of that's right and that's
you could use it I also don't know if
that's also
trauma or generational or cultural I
think it's cultural but I also think you
could always match it up with your their
ovulation schedule
like I know they're super horny like
yeah bro you know when they're ovulating
yeah you keep track of your girl's cycle
no but comment below if you guys keep
track of your significant others
menstrual cycle do you ever do the thing
where you just wake up [__] out of
nowhere yeah that was kind of this
morning that's pretty cool oh yeah that
was this morning tell me about it
um I woke up at 5 30 this morning and
then with it inside already no I wish
God I wish
oh God
no it wasn't inside already but I it
it's because that's the problem with
she she wakes up later than I do and I
wake up really early because you know I
got the kids now I gotta like take them
out I gotta like you know make sure they
don't [__] everywhere anyway but I wake
up really early and then she was
complaining about how she hasn't gotten
sleep so I can't wake up at 5 30 and be
like hey get down to mess around a
little bit yeah it's just not gonna work
so I just sat there in my feelings and
um I try to do some work on one because
you're extra horny this morning trying
to take my mind off it yeah and then
what happened that was it that's the
uneventful part it was just that was I
thought you said you guys woke up
[__] no well see I didn't know I
missed I missed that we didn't wake up
having sex no no I I thought you meant
would you wake up like
10 Hut you know no I meant like did you
ever wake up like already doing throwing
it down doing the disco for like whoa
how long have you been doing this for no
that's never happened really that's
never happened does that happen to you
frequently so before we had kids
um
it happened a couple times and that's
when I know she's ovulating oh because I
think that's your size it's the
pheromones and the hormones taking over
so strongly
that it's almost at a subconscious level
and we both wake up and we're in doggy
style and we're like how does this even
happen dude Bart you're a real sexy guy
dude that's pretty crazy yeah that's
pretty crazy you know what we might have
had this wrong all time Anthony Lee is
not the sex ever
no he's a sex actor because he's setting
those traps if you
if you're waking up out of Slumber and
you're throwing it down sometimes in in
reverse cowgirl dude that's pretty crazy
you can't get in those positions and
it's sleepy but doggies that's crazy
yeah but it is more natural though
because you just roll over and you're
just like boom right yeah and I think I
don't know the pheromones going that the
stuff that you don't even know what's
happening in the biology yeah but then
nowadays never we need Dr Andrew
huberman to give us an explanation of
why this is happening to you where you
wake up just like doing it and throwing
it down I wake up is that is that how
Taiko was conceived no
we actually kind of know where he was
conceived I think he was conceived in
England actually no way yeah yeah
because he's a UK baby I think so
because uh we didn't have our actual
honeymoon
um after we got married because we're
just so busy so like right after the
marriage we went right back to here to
work yeah and then
um for like maybe a year or two and then
we're like you know what like we've
always been like uh
we feel like oh we're kind of like an
untraditional or unconventional couple
we do unconventional work you know like
we should live life borrow rules and
stuff but then also you also feel like
some traditions have been established
for so long for a reason yeah like it
works yeah and it brings people together
you know like there's a reason why you
instead of just like eloping you ask
your your ladies uh dad can I have
permission and like hand in marriage
like there's this real classic guy yeah
there's things that you do that that
just works so we're like okay like we
never had a real honeymoon let's let's
have a honeymoon because we know once
you have a kid We're not gonna be
traveling anymore
so we um we did like this little like
Europe tour
and then
uh we didn't know like when we were
because we weren't trying but at the
time that we found out when she was
pregnant and then we backdated we're
like oh [__] that was and I think London
wow one of those tiny ass London beds
you ever been to London no never a twin
size bed is like a [__] Queen over
there and poor Geo's just falling off
the bed dude yeah her head is off and
her heels are off
her ankles are hitting the floor dude
and you know they got double faucets you
know that that's stupid so ours is like
this right hot and cold goes into one
yeah and some of the old school hotels
it's hot and cold and I don't know how
you're supposed to use it but you're
like
and and that's why they lost the war
dude that's probably why that's why
1776. am I right come on dude no because
they're getting confused by the double
faucets there's just too much time it's
just it just doesn't work right but as
far as like um you know it's funny too
when I've been coming home one of the
main things my wife is watching on the
YouTubes is your uh Barton Geo podcast
really yeah dude why
she just likes the advice you guys give
us and I started watching too and I'm
like I really like your guys's um the
stuff you guys talk about
like yeah like you did a finance one
recently yeah and me and Tiff were like
we need to be more like Martin Geo I
[__] hate the fans for that one
really why so the [__] [__] stupid
ass fans like I try to like do what they
want right yeah yeah so I'm okay cool
we're about to do some podcasts today
tell me what topics you want yeah and
then 20 30 of them Finance advice
Finance advice I'm okay cool let's take
the stab at it yeah I do it that's one
of one of our lowest viewed one and I'm
like you guys don't even want this
[__] you [__] lie to me but
that's what most people do though I feel
especially when it comes to YouTube yeah
because they're like sometimes it's the
edge of like very easily you're looking
on YouTube for educational reasons and
then two seconds later then you're
watching you know fart videos or
something more entertaining yeah
something like way easier for the
dopamine hit yeah so I feel like
everyone has the intention of watching
Finance stuff and then once you start
watching it they're like this is [__]
boring and then they just start looking
off and they go on Tick Tock while
they're watching your [__] thing but
and then and then they just don't watch
it anymore but I feel like the stuff how
you guys lay out
everything is really fascinating to me
at least maybe just because and also too
I think it's like a season of life like
the season of life that we're in we're
definitely thinking more of like how to
move forward that way yeah so when you
hear someone putting things out
as far as very objective advice that you
could take from
more like principles and Rule sets right
like I think that's like Frameworks it's
easier for me to kind of learn things
and try to implement like new habits
into my day-to-day is from that lens but
when you hear from someone who's done it
at a high level and then is continuing
to do it then you're like oh cool this
is like very practical
easy to understand advice and I feel
like that's like my some of my favorite
stuff to listen to because I'm sure
there's so many different Finance
channels that we stumble upon like
Graham Stefan did I don't know what the
hell that guy's talking about no his
stuff is really great it does good to
you but but even his stuff is a little
bit more like entertaining yeah and but
your guys's the way you guys laid it out
was just very like paint by numbers and
for me I was like this is [__] cool
so now every time I come home
she was she's always watching her
[__] podcast and you're always
talking to the Geo and Geo's looking at
you like
and I look at her face and I go yeah are
you on team Bart or team Gio sometimes I
flip-flop that's [__] up as long as I
flip-flop but most of the time
T-Mart thank you team bar baby yeah like
on the recent most financed one I think
most of them we try to like share some
of the Insight that we learned because I
feel like we always learn things the
hard way like
like Graham Stefan
people like him wasn't really around no
for sure like when we first started so a
lot of the stuff in my generation like
we all learned the hard way yeah and I
also realized
um professionals have to obey the law
so they can't tell you a lot of stuff so
it's actually like
our ability to share things like in a
non-pc political way yeah uh
and and non-like we don't have to worry
about if we're legal we're going to lose
our license like that's the way I want
to learn stuff because like I'll I'll
like ask like our accountant or CPA
about certain tax advice yeah and then
they'll keep telling me in these [__]
weird-ass words and I'm like can I do it
or not and then they'll never go like
yes or no spell it out yeah like even
when we first started like buying um
when we first started being on the
market to buy our first home I was like
oh so like what's the uh skin color of
the people that live around here I know
I'm sorry I actually can't tell you that
and then so I was like okay I'm just
gonna start pointing at things and you
say yes or no okay I was like this color
right here
and then or this color right here you
know or this color and then they'll be
like no I can't say any of that stuff
but now if I go with my friend to the
neighborhood it's not
it's not you know and so like I feel
like because of that like I like I
actually like doing the podcast yeah
because I can share this stuff that to
me felt like took forever to get those
answers because tax professionals real
estate all those guys are they're not
going to give you like the
conversational answer yeah you know oh
should I do this with my test well it
depends on your financial situation it's
like too professional and I'm like
[__] you know what my foot what
I'm trying to do just tell me can I do
it you know sounds like you're hanging
out with a lot of squares but the cool
thing about like bringing it back to JK
one of the cool things about just being
in the room with all you guys and I feel
like you guys are at a different level
in a different stage in life than like
maybe I am for sure so to hear and from
like because I kind of see you guys all
as like big Bros in here you know and
it's cool to hear from all you from like
the conversations that you and Joe have
and you and Steve have or Ryan and
Anthony or whatever it's cool to hear
you guys is so much experience that you
guys have had and there's so much like
little tidbits of
cool little
I don't say hacks but just really good
advice just basic things that I could
just
you I don't get from my circle of
friends
you know you don't get it from Frank
from Frank no we're talking about
[__] stupid stuff we're talking about
stupid stuff well like just clown down a
clown clowning around dude what does
Frank do he yeah my boyfriend yeah he
works at Trader Joe's are you guys the
same age yeah we're the same age and he
doesn't help you out with any
life advice as long as he does
you know like what like a [__] Trader
Ming sales uh that felt like an insult
I'm gonna take that personally
and yes he does he'll be like he'll be
like hey dog you gotta try this one does
he know when like the shipments come in
and you can come and get what you need
kind of like if you got if you guys need
to plug like I got a plug but like don't
blow it up you know like don't [__]
blow up the spot because I got I got an
inside guy at my Albertsons
yeah and I'm like yo how come every time
I come here there's no more fair life
and he'll be like dude there's like a
nationwide you gotta come a Tuesday in
the morning I'm like all right and I
just showed up Tuesday Morning guess
what packed the [__] ceiling off
their life all fair live baby 42 grams
or 25 6 grams of protein well I was
getting the big bottles the the actual
milkshake but you know there's there's
like a total shortage of fair life and
like Core Power and stuff really wasn't
hard to get I don't know Everyone likes
it yeah Everyone likes the protein if
you go to uh Costco yeah you can get a
whole [__] case for like I think like
six bucks or something now this is good
content we should talk about more
[__] deals and their deals you guys
want to talk about all right fast
forward to this day am I the same
or what what how has your impression of
me changed from 2023 to
2017. I've underst I I think over the
years of hanging out with you more I
realize
I kind of understand a little bit better
not maybe completely how your brain
works and how you kind of approach
things I feel like how's my brain work
I feel like you're very objective with
how you handle things like you take the
emotion out of it and I feel like that's
something that
um
I try to employ in my life now and I
feel like it's been a lot more helpful
for me to just
get things done and just to like not
take things personally you know because
I feel like for a really long time that
was something I was like really worried
about just taking things personally all
the time and I feel like that was like a
a hardship so
um
just kind of looking at things
objectively for what it is and whatever
because I think a lot of the times
whatever preconceived notions that we
have we think about a topic or a person
we establish that in our mind as truth
and we're not really
um
taking it out and looking at it into the
light and being like why do I feel this
way about this where does this thought
come from and like just taking more
questions from that like I feel like
people tend to not do that so when I see
because at first I was like dude Bart's
a robot I am a robot yeah no but you are
like you kind of are the biggest
complaint but there is
a lot of value in doing that is there
what's a time that I was a robot that
you're like
what the [__] just any JK video ever
yeah really no no not even but it's to
the point where man I can't really think
of like a
interpersonal moment that we've had
where you'll say things and I'll be like
oh that was a little harsh and then I
think about it later and be like Oh but
he was actually looking from this way I
can't really think of it that way it's
not really as like um
I can't think of a instance but from
when we have conversation well actually
even how you handled the passing with
your dad like that I was like whoa it
was it was really crazy because you were
just like I have to get X Y and Z done
it's it's crazy because all the stuff
you're going through that whole week was
a really cool example of lag you have
every excuse in the world to not get
certain things done to [__] bail on
this bail on that whatever because
you're Anthony though
I'm sorry I thought he was born it
wasn't me take that back part anyway uh
to see how you went through that whole
situation was like ah that is the true
definition of
not just discipline but just moving in a
way where you're like like kind of being
a man about [__] right because you I
feel like I we saw you actually sit with
your feelings and really
handle with
um or deal with what you're feeling and
talk about it openly and just be like
yeah this is what it is like obviously
I'm sad and I'm heartbroken but I still
need to do these things over here and
this still needs to get done because you
have responsibilities and and I feel
like you don't really see that as much
anymore and it's hard to find people
that really live by that to a certain
degree
or just to be consistent with that with
something as tragic and sad and
complicated as what you dealt with with
the passing your debt like
that is [__] high level [__] right so
um
that was definitely an example I was
like damn Mark's kind of looks like a
gangster you know like and it was and I
think we all were
I don't say yeah I think to a certain
degree inspired and just kind of like
okay time to look at our stuff a little
bit more look at our own personal that's
what I that's how I felt well I
appreciate you guys being there for me
because I was like
definitely a crazy week crazy weekend
and it was cool that like everyone was
down to stay because it was felt like
you know when you have like big news
yeah you're like [__] I gotta share and
express it with someone yeah and
everyone was down to just stay after and
hang and talk yeah and so that that
meant a lot to me too well you know full
disclosure I don't know what the [__] to
say
yeah cause it's crazy well and also too
like the way you were like hey can we
talk like can I tell you about something
I just I thought it was some JK [__] I
thought it was like some business stuff
yeah yeah and then for that bomb and I
just immediately felt like my heart sank
I felt like my stomach like dropped I
was like
oh my God it just it just caught me off
guard and then you know to see someone
that you care about go through something
like that you're just like because you
you empathize and you can't help but to
feel like oh my God what's Bart going
through right now what you're feeling
and then just kind of sitting there and
processing it and yeah it was just it
just caught me by surprise that I just
wasn't yeah it was just such a crazy
moment it was very emotional very heavy
and
um but then to see how you move from
that
going forward and then you're cracking
jokes like as we're having dinner right
after you told us I was like Jesus
Christ
no for sure for sure and and but then
again you realize like yeah that that
trait is very unique to Bart and then
you kind of understand you see how
everyone's like so different and how
they approach things and it's it's just
cool to see and I'm thankful to have a
group of guys or that I could constantly
learn from and just kind of be around
everybody you know um yeah so I'm very
thankful for this [__] show dude
this [__] show [__] show but it is
crazy
all the people you guys have brought
together over the years and to see what
you guys have built and the fact that
you guys been doing this for how many
years have you guys been doing JK news
for if I had to guess I think 13. did
you ever think you would be doing this
for this long that might be like half
[__] on my part yeah but I thought I
was gonna do it forever yeah and then I
realized did that change the world shows
you examples that things don't last
forever you know like it's crazy it's
like um like growing up I would watch
all these like you know those like oh
the NFL guys that went broke or whatever
there's all these documentaries and
shows right yeah and I'm like [__]
idiots how do you squander millions of
dollars yeah and then I remember like at
the peak of JK and then when we started
like the revenue algorithm starts
changing yeah and I'm like oh [__] I'm
not making the same I did anymore yeah
and then I could kind of extrapolate oh
[__] if I don't change my spending
habits in the next 12 months I'm gonna
be like this NFL guy yeah so you don't
actually like you you recognize it but
you don't apply it to yourself like I
want I've seen Friends start and end
I've seen all my favorite shows start
and end but you never go oh my show has
a start and and do it yeah so yeah it's
been 13 years and whenever when we're in
it I never thought we would ever end we
thought it would just keep going and
going and going for sure but fortunately
we're still going which is pretty damn
cool yeah no it's just crazy priorities
have shifted yeah
um but I did recently watch something on
grams definitely because he's like a big
numbers cruncher and I think he said
like 70 or 80 of channels stop after
five years
because you know people just evolve out
of it which kind of makes sense right
like High School's four years colleges
because people want to be this right I
think it's normal for people to get like
tired of something or just like Oh I
wanna I wanna chase the new shiny thing
yeah and even as a person you hear like
like they say even your skin is not the
same skin every seven years yeah like
you as a person aren't even the same so
why would you like the same things yeah
and then so I think he says like 90 of
channels are gone by seven years wow so
for us to be here for 13 it's pretty
cool we doubled it dude yeah you guys
doubled it so well we all doubled it
because I don't know if we could do it
without you guys without Ryan dude
without Ryan without Ryan Anthony you
Steve yeah for sure it's been a fun
group Ken's my favorite even though I
[__] hate his guts sometimes well it
was nice talking to you Nick getting to
know you for just a little bit honestly
we should do this more see
you always say that no we should no
you're because it is something this has
been a theme in my life recently and
it's just like under like trying to make
more time for and invite people to go do
things yeah I don't even know what the
inside of her house looks like I don't
want to see it I don't know you're new
still I haven't seen your new still
haven't seen your new kids new stuff is
pretty sweet I haven't seen any of that
stuff I've never even sat in your car
have I I don't even sat in your car yeah
you're not going to sit in my car why
not because your car is way cooler my
car I want to sit in your [__] car I
don't know what it feels like I've never
sat in your Miata no you not everyone
gets to see the Miata bro I never sat in
your car let's be real but anyways it
was nice getting to know you on a
personal level on this show you feel
like you got to know me a little bit
more a little bit more
damn that sounded like not that good no
it's really good yeah because I didn't
know you guys were [__] down the
clown that's pretty cool I thought we
were gonna do this longer man no next
time we're gonna do it if you want to
see a part two let us know and then let
us know which other combinations you
would like to see yeah and maybe even
further that
um if there's certain topics that you
would like the pair to talk about let us
know in the comments below and it's here
in the next JK overtime bye guys